well hello there reject nation so tom
holland
this whole week they've been teasing how
he's going to be doing an interview
with variety and you know in promotion
with cherry and uh all anyone cares
about it does he talk about spider-man 3
and apparently he does
so there's about a minute and 44 seconds
that we were able
to uh download right now what we'll do
is you know we'll give a reaction to it
but you know we'll actually like try to
break it down in the moment
to respond to it yeah engage with him i
haven't seen this yet but i do see
he has glasses on tom holland's maturing
that's right
he's becoming a man let's do it
let's talk about this little independent
film you're working on called you know
spider-man 3
tentatively titled i just got to say
right up front i'm so sick of that joke
with big blockbuster movies
oh it's an independent movie it's so
rich
what's going on here and like there's
all these rumors man i'm i'm the film
editor he's just pushing like getting
he's pushing getting bombarded by
different angles man people are like we
need to know
about that i mean obviously i can't
really say anything
uh i mean you could tell us what
happened like that's pretty
simple it's like do you know what's
funny is like
i nearly told you then i know we'll get
so close
because we're friends and you're not
having said you're not i believe that
coming from him we've been on this cool
what fifteen minutes
yeah um you know i gotta say
the fact that he even hesitated at that
moment you can see it in his eyes
where his eyes are like going to the
ending of the script when he's asked
that question yeah
the thought of the ending and i don't
think anyone was really prepared for the
ending of far from home
to be as big caliber and as high stakes
as it was which is of course led us to
be even that much more excited for this
spider-man 3 film
and also it's just really charming to
see how like even
his old struggle it must be a hell of an
ending you know
yeah we sat down at this i was like a
minute and 44 seconds is enough time to
spoil
a lot of stuff about it so it props to
tomorrow
um i can say that it's the most
ambitious
standalone superhero you've ever met
nice
sit down and you read the script and you
see what they're trying to do
and they are succeeding it's really
impressive
i've never seen a standalone superhero
movie quite like it
and um and i'm just you know again that
lucky little
who happens to be spider-man wow
okay it's interesting to read his both
pauses
and his inflections because he seems
very considered and thoughtful with the
words he chooses
just the way he says like and they are
achieved like they are
nailing it or whatever he said they're
like i i believe him but also like it's
getting
my anticipation to the point that i'm
almost anxious now
wait a minute let's do that back at luke
again i can say that it's the most
ambitious
stand-alone superhero movie ever made
it's so hard not to read into this [ __ ]
because
you watched him choose those shoes
ambitious pause
it's definitely a multiverse movie stand
alone
it's like i found the right word you
watch and pause right there in that
moment
it's so difficult not to try to like
nitpick any little thing he's doing
because of all the rumors we've heard
the fact that the interviewer
posed this question with with like
the multiverse topic at hand i mean the
fact that he's saying
it is the most ambitious stand-alone i
mean captain america's civil war
technically would be qualified as a
stand-alone superhero movie yeah but
there's a whole bunch of characters in
it
some of these rumors got to be true
right
and most foreign i mean it's got to
imply that it's got to be one of the
biggest that's the e this this was a
deft way of saying
a lot with only two words that are not
specific
to any of the rumors or details so fun
being a marvel fan is the kind of [ __ ]
you do right you're just like
just read it what is it man you sit down
and you read the script
and you see what they're trying to do
and they are succeeding
yeah they're taking bold swings
[Music]
quite and i'm just you know
again that lucky little who happens to
be spider-man he said [ __ ]
he said lucky little [ __ ] i can't
really tell you any more than that
i'm just as excited as everyone else to
see it let alone be a part of it
um but uh but no you guys officially
don't know you have more
shooting to do oh here we go we got a
lot more to do yeah we started before
christmas we shot like seven weeks
before christmas we
stopped for christmas break and then we
start shooting
i think next week i'm not sure we'll see
if you have to put a suit on here
just basically go where i'm told and do
as i'm told i don't really know anything
that's happened
all right wait a minute so what's the
shooting schedule that he's declared
let's hear this again
you have more shooting to do or we got a
lot more to do yeah we started before
christmas we shot like seven weeks
before christmas we
stopped for for the christmas break and
then we start shooting
i think next week only seven weeks yeah
not enough to get a trailer apparently
for teaser footage
what the hell man jesus thompson artists
on this you got clout man you know how
much we want it
i'm not out here take your time take
your time on that trailer you don't want
to botch that but then that would also
make sense too
with the fact that we've been hearing so
much of especially with the
tobey maguire situation specifically
about not being able to officially lock
him down just yet with all the
negotiations if they've only been
shooting for seven weeks
i could fathom that gives you enough
time if he ends up
not saying yes if he ends up backing out
of it that's enough time for them to
rework this they shoot these movies for
like three to six months on average oh
yeah and i would imagine that yeah you
could just start with all the stuff
that's our core cast who we know is
gonna be here who's all contracted and
stuff yeah that seems just like
efficient
i mean yeah of course they got a lot
more to do that's always got the biggest
sandal on superheroes
it's fun watching tom holland struggle
to not give [ __ ] away
it's among my favorite parts of of the
auxiliary
marvel process you could tell he's
having a difficult time nobody does it
like
tom holland and to be the most ambitious
standalone superhero film ever made
all right guys all right well the hype
is real
i mean you'd think with the title like
multiverse of madness
that was doctor strange that that would
be the most ambitious
one but this spider-man film i'm betting
the majority of what we've been hearing
will be true
not all but i feel like majority at
least what they're attempting
i imagine a lot of the people will show
up but maybe not as we expect them
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that notification
bell hit that like button
last but not least
my man been loving chatting with you
lately and recently you paid us a very
nice compliment had a discussion about
therapy
and then you were saying like we've been
kind of like your therapy over at
patreon i thought that was such a
sweet thing to say to us so
as your new therapist i want to say
take that knife and end
yourself that's good advice yeah
especially considering all the things
you've said you can't turn this around
that knife i've always wanted to wield
that level of power this is what
influencers
are all those that love us this is what
you have
taking this so seriously trying out some
new shout outs buddy
love you man thank you so much for being
a part of page looking forward to
chatting with you some more and
seriously thanks for all the
recommendations on the shows and such
and i love all the comments you've been
leaving thank you bud
stay alive longer than us
[Music]